hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Fyodor
Dostoevsky's notes from underground
there's a very interesting set of
discussions about the workings of anger
and a few other associated effects and
Dostoyevsky's character who represents
an intellectual will make a fundamental
distinction between how ordinary people
or what he calls the man of action or
man of character the person who actually
is something how they handle their anger
and indeed act upon and express their
anger and manage to discharge it and
what takes place differently for the
intellectual who's unable to fully or
even really halfway deal with their
feeling of anger and the things that led
to it the legitimate concerns that they
they have now this discussion takes
place more or less in two places
although you can see threads of it
running through the rest of the work one
of them is in Chapter three and then the
other is in Chapter five where there's
section three and section five and so if
we think about how anger works there's
an assumption that dose task is making
that we all
ready understand what's going on when we
get angry and and some of us may not in
fact have a very good handle upon how
this works when we get angry we have
that effect we have that emotional
reaction because we feel that something
was done that shouldn't be the case and
it could be a person doing it it could
be an animal where have a lot of anger
problems it could be the book not not
reading right or the wind blowing on us
the wrong way but whatever it happens to
be he even talks about getting angry
because you've got a toothache and why
does God give me this or why does the
universe
give me a toothache let's stick just two
people so we get angry when somebody
does something that we think shows us
that they don't value us as much as
themselves or the same that other people
do or that they value other people we
feel a loss of status not just an injury
you know somebody bumping you in the
street can make you angry not just
because the bump provokes a physical set
of you know causes and effects a chain
reaction as we say within your system
and you know evolutionary biologist I
don't got your adrenaline going it got
your adrenaline going precisely because
there's a cognitive aspect to anger
namely you think that people shouldn't
bump you like that because bumping you
shows you that they don't value you
right that they think that you are
somebody who's worthy of being bumped we
could go on and on and on with all sorts
of other examples but whatever we want
to think in this case we get angry
because we think something was done that
was wrong and it shouldn't have happened
to us and that SOB
shouldn't have done it so we take some
sort of offense we think that there's
some sort of injustice and that's why we
often think well you know they did it to
me I'm gonna go bump them or somebody
says something mean to us and we have a
great term for this that is originated
in recent years we clap back right
somebody says something cutting we say
something cutting to them and some
people are quite good at this others
will
stew for a while and think of what the
right thing was to say to that person
but unfortunately they've already left
right and we're all familiar with this
if we don't suffer from anger ourselves
every one of us knows somebody who does
and we've seen people act upon this so
we think that there's some sort of
injustice that took place and we may
feel a sense of humiliation or we might
not feel humiliated per se but we might
be like that that person lowered my
status I need to do something about it
now how does the ordinary person what he
calls the spontaneous person the person
of action the person of character how do
they typically handle these offenses and
getting angry they do so in a way very
different than the intellectual they
seek revenge and they seek revenge
confidently they go out there you know
you take their stapler and don't return
it they won't necessarily burn the whole
place down unless you've done it a whole
bunch of times some of you may catch the
reference there to a person who is in in
some respect kind of similar to the
underground man but you take it and you
don't return it well that's fine they'll
go and take your mug off your desk or
something else or they'll bring it up in
a meeting and call you out about it or
they'll send an email you know with a
picture of the missing stapler and say
you need to return this jackass or
whatever else they want to throw in
there and you know it depends on what
the offense is and how their mindset
works and a defendant depends on a lot
of social rules to what counts as
adequate revenge but people in fact do
that might be just giving somebody the
finger or you know giving them a dirty
look or not talking to them there's all
sorts of ways to do it but this person
will do so confidently they're not going
to say oh I don't know if this is the
right thing to do but I'm gonna do it
anyways I'm gonna punch them in the face
know if they don't think it's the right
thing to do if they think that's
crossing too many lines and they won't
punch them they'll do something else or
maybe they won't take revenge at all and
don't say ask
talks about this person as feeling
themselves in the right there's there's
two very interesting ways that he talks
about this early on in chapter 3 says
it's you know normal people when they
are humiliated
they will repay the person in kind why
because they because of their innate
stupidity they consider revenge as
merely justice revenge is what is right
a little bit further on he talks about
primary and secondary causes primary
causes are the things that really make
us do what we do so our real motives or
stuff like that and we often mistake
those for secondary causes things that
are caused by the primary cause and we
take that to be what's really going on
but you know we're actually wrong about
that and he says that when I spoke of
vengeance it said that a man avenges
himself because he thinks it's the just
thing to do what does he mean this
implies he's found the primary reason
the basis for his action which in this
case is justice
why is he clapping back why is he
slashing that's persons tires why is he
saying that mean thing to the neighbor
or the spouse or the mailman or whoever
happens to be because that is justice
and they are embodying it in their
action it actually makes them feel good
they're like damn straight I told that
person and you know now everything is
right in the world says this gives him
foolproof peace of mind so he avenges
himself without qualms efficiently
certain throughout he's acting fairly
and honestly the person can be self
assured no that doesn't mean that later
on they might not see things a little
bit differently you know they do
something to somebody and then they find
out that it has had some tragic
consequence and now they feel remorse
about it but that's not going to change
how they felt at the time
and there's you know if they don't see
any results that that really bother them
they're not gonna feel bad about it
they're gonna be like well I shouldn't
have lost my temper but they had it
coming to them that's the way ordinary
people deal with it according to
Dostoevsky and a person who's angry like
that he also mentions they will sort of
stop when they come to the metaphorical
equivalent of a stone wall so that could
be the boss saying all right you're
ticked off knock it off because if you
don't you know work together on this
team I'm gonna fire both of you or it
could be the police or it could be
whoever right if there's something that
that represents a absolute impediment
the person stops up short by the wall
they're like oh okay
you can't go any further I guess we'll
let things go or they may say that's not
a real wall I'm gonna burst through it
and consequences be damned I'm gonna get
my revenge and they still feel good
about that so that is the person of
action how is anger different for the
intellectual it's not in how they
initially feel it I mean the the
intellectual can take offense a little
bit more easily because they're more
hyper conscious they will perceive
slights where perhaps they aren't
actually intended or where they are
actually intended and the ordinary
person would be too dumb to actually
pick up on the fact that somebody is
showing them contempt or is mistreating
them or is you know dis valuing them in
in some way and so they they feel the
anger they sense that there's some sort
of injustice something wrong that's
taking place that they've been injured
that they've been harmed that they've
been insulted that they've been lowered
in some way cheated perhaps and they
don't like it they don't like it any
more than the ordinary person but what
they do what the anger is different and
now why is that
Dostoevsky doesn't say well they have
different habits or you know they've
been brought up differently no one has
to do with their very intellectual
capacity
in some respect turning against them
something that they can't prevent by the
way so he talks about the intellectual
person not being able to identify the
revenge that they would like to take
because they feeling you're like
everybody else with justice why not they
they can see further they realize that
their motives are not as pure as the
other person might think that they are
they know that when they act in in the
same way as everybody else they're not
doing the right thing they may even have
a sense that it's never okay to injure
another person in revenge or retaliation
or punishment or however we want to put
it they may doubt whether that's all
right they can't have that nice safe
confidence that I'm doing the right
thing by popping this person in the face
or you know giving them a nice little
zing or something along those lines they
can't identify their revenge as justice
and so Dostoevsky talks about the mouse
that he uses the word Mouse for this
person because they retreat into a
little hole he says let's assume it's
been humiliated and that it wishes to
avenge itself it's possible that there's
more spite accumulated in it than the
the person of nature and truth this
nauseating despicable petty desire to
repay the offender in kind may squeak
more disgustingly in the mouse than in
the natural man who considers revenge is
merely justice whereas the mouse with
its heightened consciousness is bound to
deny the justice of its of it then it
says it finds itself mired in questions
and doubts and qualms when it comes to
actually taking action well I'm not sure
if this is the right time to do it you
know maybe there's going to be some
unintended consequences or some
spillover or you know do I really want
to damage this relationship now the
really
ship kind of sucks because I'm being
mistreated but joy don't want to make it
worse will they retaliate against me
will they will they see me as as like
standing up for myself or will they
think that I'm going too far and being
aggressive and we can go on and on and
on with similar questions Dostoevsky
doesn't actually raise all of these but
he leaves it open to us because we may
have experience of this too to think
about that so they get mired in
questions and doubts and they're unable
to take action they hesitate what does
that lead to well you know when you
hesitate in the face of somebody who is
perhaps bullying you they're gonna bully
you some more they're gonna humiliate
you some more they're gonna be like oh
look at them they can't stand up for
themselves and it leads to more and more
humiliation which leads to further anger
he puts it in a very graphic way he says
each question brings up so many more
unanswered questions a fatal pool of
sticky muck is formed consisting of the
mouse's doubts and torments as well as
the gobs of spit aimed at it by the
practical amount of action who stand
around like judges and dictators and
laugh lustily a titular throats are sore
so this is a painful sort of experience
what does he do instead he avenges
himself every once in a while he comes
out of the mouse hole and stick somebody
but it does so in ways that are petty or
we might say today passive aggressive
and they're generally unsuccessful he
talks about his great line here the the
mouse the person the intellectual who's
humiliated he says it does so in spurts
from behind the stove anonymously
doubting its vengeance is right that it
will succeed feeling as a result it will
hurt itself as a hundred times more than
it hurt the one against who against whom
its revenge is directed who probably
won't even feel enough of an itch to
scratch himself so you know
you you save up all these these lines
and you're gonna put them in an email to
the person who's been bothering you
you're gonna really show them and they
read it they're like ha ha
good good joke man and you're like this
is supposed to crush you and you're
they're like oh sorry yeah okay I'm
totally crushed and then you know curses
all right
the intellectual is not able to get the
revenge that they want because they
can't produce the result of pain or
anger or whatever it happens to be in
the other person the revenge that they
take is ineffective it's too late it's
perhaps too too intellectual to
cognitive to well thought out for the
person they're like I don't know what
all these words that you're saying about
me mean but I mean sounds pretty cool
man you know you're supposed to be
crushed by this well okay I'm so crushed
it's just not going to work
he also tracks a little bit later about
and this is in Chapter five about one's
anger sort of dissolving away he says
that when when I get or when when the
the person gets angry they're they're
not able to keep it up in part because
the laws of nature dissolve it there's a
kind of what does he say
disintegration that's that's chemical
like everything else as I think that the
anger vanishes the reasons for it
evaporate the responsible person has
never found the insult becomes an insult
no longer but drop just a stroke of fate
just like a toothache for which no one
can be held responsible when you know
enough about the world and about the
people who say bruise you and seem to
insult you you might still get angry but
your anger dissipates because you're
like well they are a bunch of idiots who
grew up in this environment
and think that this actually makes sense
and I'm not going to change them by
imposing my wrath upon them and you
gradually lose your anger now does that
mean that you you are now in a happy
state of equanimity or something no you
just have the anger itself being away
but it leaves other negative things in
its wake according to him and it doesn't
produce anything good the other thing
that does happen is that the underground
man or the mouse the intellectual keeps
remembering and ruminating upon the
things that hurt them they may even be
adding to it he talks in another chapter
about imagining insults and imagining
offenses and this is another problem
with with being intellectual it makes it
difficult to let go of grudges it makes
it difficult to see that the anger is in
part something that we are ourselves
manufacturing and contributing to and it
leads to this this you could say swamp
within the person where anger can slowly
get transmuted into something that's no
longer quite so healthy no longer quite
so wholesome and becomes something
similar to what later on nature will
call resentiment and I think that is
part of what Dostoevsky
is describing and diagnosing within the
intellectuals of his own time through
this character of the underground men
you